welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with britain
celebrating queen elizabeth's
unprecedented 70-year reign this weekend
the queen missed friday's events due to
her health but she may be at this
evening's concert outside buckingham
palace holly williams is in london lucky
girl good morning to you
good morning the british are famous for
their reserve and their stiff upper lip
but they can also throw a party like no
other and this is a four day party to
celebrate the queen's platinum jubilee
marking 70 years as monarch
soldiers in enormous hats a royal gun
salute
the celebrity power of the royal family
with their adorable children
and a military flyover spelling out
exactly what it's all about
70 years of service by this 96 year old
lady
[Applause]
it's a part of the british culture it's
a part of the history and it's wonderful
because we get days like this where we
can celebrate with them we're from cbs
news
for many here the queen's platinum
jubilee is an opportunity to say thank
you we are her subjects and she is the
most wonderful woman
the queen watched the military parade on
thursday from the balcony of buckingham
palace surrounded by three generations
of her descendants
and that night at windsor castle she led
a ceremony symbolizing unity
more than 3 000 beacons were lit around
the country and the commonwealth
most here can't remember their nation
without her she ascended the throne at
just 25
on friday there was a service of
thanksgiving with the royals again out
in force but the palace said the queen
had felt discomfort at the parade and
reluctantly decided not to attend she's
got bad knees she's frightened of
falling over it's quite understandable
hugo vickers is a royal historian we
mustn't ask too much of her 70 years on
the throne as long as she can exist and
and be happy that's the main thing
but making her first official public
appearance in the uk since moving to the
u.s over two years ago was megan duchess
of sussex with her husband prince harry
they appeared all smiles
hugo vickers puts it down to forgiveness
although i personally am slightly less
forgiving of what they've said and what
they've done it's interesting to see the
queen showing this compassion to them
today is the first birthday of harry and
megan's daughter lilibet and there are
unconfirmed reports they'll be throwing
a birthday party for her meanwhile here
at buckingham palace they're preparing
for a jubilee concert tonight with
performances by elton john lin-manuel
miranda and diana ross michelle
wow now that is a lineup holly thank you
so much